cifra recorde en Colombia
95.000 personas han vivido confinadas en
los primeros nueve meses de 2022 es el
número más alto en 10 años pero no es un
confinamiento de pandemia sino por el
conflicto armado personas que no pueden
salir de sus casas ni comunidades
al lado otra cifra de impacto
74.000 personas han sido Víctimas de
desplazamiento masivo es decir por la
violencia han tenido que dejar sus
comunidades es el último informe de la
oficina de la ONU para la coordinación
de asuntos humanitarios que pese a todo
reconocen que en el mes de septiembre ha
descendido la violencia en medio de las
intenciones del gobierno de Gustavo
Petro de lograr la que ha llamado pacto
tal el equipo humanitario en Colombia
formado por más de un centenar de
agencias también dijo que el 15% de la
población necesita asistencia
humanitaria Mientras que el país vive
una infrafinanciación para afrontar
causas culturales pese a todo este
jueves el consejo de seguridad de las
Naciones Unidas renovó la misión
humanitaria Un año más la adopción
unánime de esta resolución hoy demuestra
el compromiso continuo del Consejo de
Seguridad con la paz en Colombia y con
la implementación integral del acuerdo
de paz Mientras tanto el canciller de
Colombia Álvaro Leyva dijo en una cumbre
de cancilleres europeos y
latinoamericanos que España y chile
serán acompañantes del nuevo proceso de
paz en Colombia